y este frente de gerzón es estratégico
porque fue el lugar por donde entraron
más rápido los rusos al comienzo de la
guerra estamos a 5 km de las posiciones
rusas pero a 60 de ese puerto de gerzón
que ellos tomaron muy al comienzo de la
guerra y la primera gran ciudad que
tuvieron en su control
si le atacan desde otro lugar observamos
desde donde atacan para corregir la
dirección de nuestra artillería
se escuchará su explosión en la
distancia
y los ordenantes corramos al refugio
ah
está la atención con la que conviven los
soldados día tras día en el frente
para qué
[Música]
muy al comienzo de la guerra los rusos
alcanzaron a llegar a 20 kilómetros al
norte de este lugar y tomar el control
de muchas de las poblaciones a comienzos
de marzo los ucranianos comenzaron una
ofensiva y a partir del 29 de ese mes
tienen el control de esta posición
esta población unos kilómetros más atrás
hay un control de las fuerzas rusas
entonces estas mujeres tuvieron que
tomar decisiones difíciles al hoyo con
su hijo de 4 años y las mayores se
quedaron vivimos aquí al comienzo no
consideramos salir corriendo nunca
creímos que algo así podría pasar
empuja que pujó integran a mi casa
robaron los calcetines comida y nada más
sólo rompieron mi puerta y por lo tanto
duele por la vista
se ha hablado de la posibilidad de una
ofensiva rusa tanto por el lado de
mykolaiv camino a odessa o al lado de
kribi ry camino a sap orilla todo
viniendo desde la ciudad de gerson para
lo que nos hemos encontrado aquí es una
posición estable de defensa y por el
contrario se habla de la posibilidad de
una contraofensiva ucraniana tanto desde
este frente como desde mykolaiv para
retomar gerson